vous allez pouvoir découvrir les plus
beaux artéfacts humains que nous avons
eu la chance de récupérer à droite à
gauche et au milieu imaginez le monde
dans 20.000 ans plus exactement en l'an
2023 c'est ce que tente de montrer le
temps des humains un spectacle immersif
réalisé par la compagnie Pixum alors
on vous emmène dans une épopée
archéologique
dans le futur en 2223 où les humains ont
disparu et l'espèce d'après les humains
font une exposition archéologique sur
les humains une rétrospective un peu
comme nous on va dans des expos sur les
dinosaures bah là c'est une exposition à
nous avec des objets de notre quotidien
qui sont détournés et avec des guides
qui expliquent aux gens à quoi pouvaient
bien servir ses objets que les humains
utilisent un voyage à travers le temps
c'est ainsi que se vit le spectacle en
déambulant dans plusieurs décors les
participants redécouvrent leur propre
monde cette manière de d'exposer comme
des vraies œuvres des vraies choses côté
retrouver par des archéologues alors
qu'en fait c'est c'est un bric-à-brac de
bordel et du coup c'est hyper drôle de
voir ça de manière sérieuse alors que tu
allais pas du tout elle nous a emmené
dans un univers trop marrant et donc moi
j'ai adoré parce que j'aime bien les
choses de Maroc plusieurs thèmes sont
évoqués notamment celui de
l'environnement un sujet qui est cher à
Pixum on appartenait avec la
Ressourcerie avec qui on fait un échange
d'objets et de meubles la Ressourcerie
va nous passer des meubles nous prêter
des meubles ou des objets dont on va
faire une valorisation artistique on
fait pas que parler d'écologie on
pratique directement
l'écologie qu'on aimerait voir dans le
monde à travers nos techniques de
création et de production porté par le
département des Yvelines le temps des
humains se veut accessible à tous il
nous questionne sur nos modes de
consommation avec humour un spectacle à
découvrir jusqu'au 15 janvier